sending text messages through your app
can bring the user experience to the
next level in this lesson I have an
angular app where users can order a
pizza for delivery my goal is to update
the users with a text message every time
their order status changes so when the
pizza goes from cooking to on its way
that user gets notified directly in
their phone to handle the text messaging
we're going to use an API called Twilio
combined with firebase cloud functions
let's start by learning a little bit
more about Twilio from their promo video
Twilio is a global communications
platform for developers with our API and
a few lines of code you can add
messaging voice and video to your
applications in the programming language
you already use so after we sign up for
a Twilio account they're going to assign
us a phone number and we can use that
phone number to send text messages to
our users you can sign up without a
credit card and they'll give you a 15
dollar credit to experiment with the API
so once you've signed up make note of
your phone number as well as your API
keys which we're going to use to build
the firebase cloud function but before
we get to that point we're first going
to build the angular component for the
front-end so i've generated a new
component called pizza status and it's
going to use the reactive forms module
so we need to make sure to add that to
the import section in our ng module
we're using a reactive form because we
need to validate the phone number
carefully when we send it to Twilio it
needs to be an e 164 format which is a
string that looks like this the country
code with a plus sign followed by at the
full ten digit phone number so let's see
how we can make this possible in the
pizza status component we are going to
break the phone number down into four
different form inputs and then when we
send that data back to firebase it's
going to be the fully formatted II 1 64
string and for this lesson in firebase I
just have a single test order in there
to simulate how this could work in the
component itself we'll first import the
angularfire database as well as the
reactive form parts that we need then
we'll set a variable for the form itself
and set that to the type of form group
and then order we'll represent the data
in firebase then we can add the angular
fire database and form builder to the
constructor and during ng on an it will
build the form which will define here in
a second and then we'll set the order
to the object that we have saved in
firebase the next thing I'm going to do
is create a helper function to validate
the min and Max length of any given form
input the reason I'm doing this is to
avoid repeating these validators for
every single format but but they're just
validating that the input value is a
number and that it's within a certain
length from here we'll use form builder
to create the actual form so we create a
method called build form and then we
define our number form as a form builder
group then we define form controls for
the country code the area code the
prefix and the line number this will
allow us to capture these values in a
form input but we still need to format
it as e1 64 to do that we can define a
getter and we can just grab the value
from the form then concatenate all the
values together in order and add a plus
sign and we're good to go
now we can send this value to firebase
when the user submits the form we
already have the ordered data as a
firebase object observable so we can
just call ordered update with the phone
number now let's put this all together
in the HTML the first thing I do here is
set a template variable called pizza
based on the order observable so we do
that by calling order async as pizza
then I want to add a custom class for
each possible orders state that the
pizza can be in we can do this with the
built in ng class directive and angular
you use ng class by passing it an object
where the keys and that object are the
classes you want to apply and the value
is an expression that resolves to true
or false so here we'll do pizza status
submitted and we'll do that is dark CSS
class then we'll add a couple more
possible statuses such as on its way
from the delivery driver and delivered
to the end user
then we're going to jump down here to
the reactive form and we make this warm
reactive by first adding a form element
and then doing form group to our number
form that we defined in the type script
then when the swarms submitted we use
this ng submit event and we'll update
the phone number in firebase also with
that function we defined in the type
script from here we'll build the actual
form inputs and all we have to do is to
form control name attribute that
corresponds to the key in the build form
function we defined earlier so that's
the country code area code etc then
lastly we'll add a submit button to the
form that is disabled if the form is
invalid just to prevent accidental
numbers being sent to firebase and then
we can also use this to send a
validation message to the user by just
doing ng if along with for number form
invalid and number form touched which
will show the user a validation message
if they've started to interact with the
form and it's invalid and the final
touch is to show the user the number
that the text messages will be sent to
after it's been updated in firebase so
if we go into the app we can type in the
form and we can see we get the red phone
number is not valid message until it is
valid and then we can actually update it
in firebase so now everything's in place
to start sending text messages we just
need to build the firebase cloud
function I've added a couple extra
buttons here just to make this a little
bit easier to show whenever these
buttons get clicked they will update the
status in firebase which will trigger
the cloud function and tell Twilio to
send the text message you could also
just edit these values manually in the
firebase console if you find that easier
so the first thing you need to do is
initialize cloud functions if they're
not already you can do that by running
in firebase init and then once you've
done that we need to set the Twilio api
keys as environment variables we can do
that with firebase functions config set
and you can also just copy and paste
this from the full lesson code from
there make sure you're in the functions
directory then we can install that
Twilio helper package for nodejs with
NPM install Twilio with save flag okay
now we can go into index j s and build
the actual cloud function we first
import the admin database and initialize
it with our firebase config from there
we can import Twilio and we'll
initialize that with the environment
variables that we set earlier then we
also need to set a variable for the
phone number that was given to us by
Twilio you could actually set this as an
environment variable instead of
hard-coding it like I am here then I'm
going to put together another validation
function for the e1
sixty-four format this time I just
checked the number against a regular
expression that will return true if it
meets that pattern so we'll build the
actual cloud function by doing exports
text status and then we'll do a database
cloud function that references the
status point in the database so in this
case it's orders with the order push key
and then the status property and then we
can use the on update trigger to run
this function whenever the value changes
but it won't run the function on create
or delete operations which is exactly
what we want when this function is
triggered will first save the order key
so we can reference that point in the
database to pull all the data for a
particular order so we can do that by
running admin database and point it to
the order key so we can pull the order
data once and then once we have that
value back we'll return it to another
promise at this point we have all the
data we need to build the text message
and send the API call off to Twilio so
we'll get the current order status then
we'll get the phone number associated
with that order and then we'll run our
validation function one more time just
so we don't send any unnecessary request
to Twilio if it's not the right format
we'll just go ahead and throw an error
and to send a text all we need to do is
define three different values and that's
the text body itself that's the actual
message the end-user will see then we
define the message to the numbers being
sent to which is the user's number and
the number of the message is being sent
from which is our Twilio account phone
number then to actually make this API
call and send the text to the user we
just need to call client messages create
and pass it the text message as the
argument this is going to return a
promise also so we can just call then
and at this point we'll also catch any
errors so that's all it takes to start
sending text messages to your users it's
pretty simple when you think about how
powerful that feature can be after you
deploy the function to firebase you
should be able to go into the app and
update the status and then you'll see
that text message come through on
whichever phone number you
I did that's it for SMS text with Twilio
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to get
involved in this project consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get a free copy in
my book as well as one on one project
consulting thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon
[Music]